so we're asked how many liters of soda
do we have for the party and they give
us all of this other information and so
what I encourage you to pause this video
and think about which of this
information you actually need to answer
this first question and then to try to
answer the question how many liters of
soda do we have for the party so pause
now so let's look at this information 20
people are coming to the party but this
doesn't help us let us know how many
liters of soda we actually have so let's
we don't we can ignore this we have
purchased five bottles of soda for the
party well this seems useful so we're
going to have five bottles of soda so
that's one two three four and five
bottles of soda so that's that's this
piece of information right over here we
have purchased five bottles of soda for
the party if only we now knew how much
soda is in each bottle now the other
piece of information the party will last
for three hours well this has nothing to
do with how many liters of soda we have
each model has two liters of soda now
this is interesting each bottle has two
liters of soda so this is 2 liters this
is two litres this is two litres this is
two litres and that is two litres so if
we wanted to figure out the total number
of liters of soda that we have we have
five bottles five bottles and each of
them are two liters each so we have five
times two and what is that equal to well
5 times 2 is the same thing as two plus
two plus two plus two plus two you have
five tubes added together so this is
going to be equal to let me write this
down two plus two plus two plus two plus
two which is equal to 2 4 6 8 10 5 times
2 is 10 we have 10 liters of soda for
the party and we were able to answer it
without even looking at this last one
this last one tells us how many bottles
of soda we had for the picnic last week
which doesn't seem related at all to our
current party